ERIC ROSENBACH: This
may sound crazy, but one
of the assignments in
this course is for you
to figure out how to put a cat on Mars.
Why do we do this?
Because it's a great
hypothetical example
that makes you think about the
strategy for a complex project
and then plan through
all of the processes
you need to have in place for
successful strategy execution.
I'm Eric Rosenbach, Harvard Professor
and former Pentagon Chief of Staff
and Assistant Secretary of Defense for
Homeland Defense and Global Security.
During my time working as Chief of
Staff at the largest organization
in the world, I worked on and witnessed
very complex issues of strategy
execution on a near-daily basis.
Now, I want to try and help others
improve their ability to have impact.
In this course, I will lead you through
real life public sector challenges
to illustrate how purposely
developed public strategies lead
to long term adoption and success.
One of the great things
about this course
is that you're going to learn
directly from individuals
who have worked on executing complex
strategies in the real world.
For example, Juliette Kayyem worked
as the Assistant Secretary of Homeland
Security.
Oni Blair is currently the
Executive Director of ACLU Texas.
And you'll even hear from Ash Carter,
the former Secretary of Defense.
When I teach this class
here at the Kennedy School,
my students are really excited to
learn about how you get things done.
It's very rare that there's a
course on strategy execution,
and that's what it's all about.
They want to have impact in the
world and make a difference,
and this class helps them
learn the tools to do that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]